this happening just moments ago that is
president Donald Trump assigning
executive orders this executive action
to withdrawal from TPP along with an
executive action to limit abortion
funding overseas and also in order for
federal hiring freeze except for the
military that was just moments ago
President Donald Trump among the
executive actions he was taking they're
withdrawing from the TPP which he calls
quote great thing for the American
worker want to bring back Michael McKee
who is our international economics and
policy correspondent so what does this
mean we're effectively no longer parts
of the TPP process which hadn't been
ratified anyway yeah and it wasn't going
to be so it's what you call low-hanging
fruit the executive orders he signed
today we haven't heard if he's signing
one to start renegotiating NAFTA which
would be somewhat meaningful the idea of
withdrawing from TPP the 12-nation
agreement among Pacific Rim companies to
lower tariffs and non-tariff barriers
and non-tariff barriers of the key thing
wasn't going to get approved in the US
so it really doesn't matter all that
much the question is is Trump going to
do something else is he going to propose
something to try to bring those
countries into a fairer or freer or both
trading arrangement with the United
States federal hiring freeze every
president signs a federal hiring freeze
when they first start out because of
course government is always the enemy to
the incoming president we'll see how
long that lasts and of course Donald
Trump has won
open positions that he needs to fill and
then finally the abortion one this is
one that goes back and forth between the
Democrats and the Republicans any
organization that gets federal funding
not allowed to use that money to provide
abortion services overseas it's called
the Mexico City doctrine and it has been
something that when the Democrats are in
power gets proved when the Republicans
are in power gets pulled back so nothing
really unexpected so far today Mike is
China rubbing its hands in glee does
this cede control of trade in Asia to
China which of course wasn't part of the
TPP well it gives them a big leg up
because the United States is sort of
withdrawn from this there are several
other trade groups that
they're trying to get a treaty together
and China has taken the lead on one of
those to try to pull some of these TPP
countries in now China doesn't have a
fully convertible currency which makes
it more difficult to sign a free trade
agreement so it doesn't mean that that
gives them an automatic win but it does
give them a leg up and negotiating and
that's something that US officials had
been concerned about they had wanted to
use the TPP as leverage against China
look we've got all these big countries
you're not in the club if you will agree
to some of our demands we'll let you in
now they're not gonna be able to do that
and the offshore renin be trading at six
point eight one eight one now
strengthening today I don't want to
overstate it but it does look like
markets are taking just as small like
lower markets are not treating this as
very market friendly at the moment
well it isn't market friendly until we
see what replaces it because free trade
obviously will the lack of a free trade
agreement will make it harder for us to
export goods overseas and to import
goods and we have companies on both
sides of that equation so at this point
they want to see what happens going
forward but again none of these
executive orders are unexpected and none
of them have a far-reaching effect in
the short run and the longer run the
lack of TPP might weigh on the US
economy but it isn't going to hurt
anybody right now because it wasn't in
effect all right